how's it going bros my name is pewdiepie
welcome back to minecraft what up sven
how you doing my main
have you seen bank wait who the hell are
you
huh you just sitting here on eggs oh
that was your friend
don't care get away from here shush
shush all right as you can see
the meatball is complete it's old
tech i put some tape on it it's clean
now
i got so many comments saying that i
should put the bees in there
so i prepare that a little bit we're
gonna do that today that's the main goal
i want to get honey that's all i want
that's for you my man
not for you get off my property or i'll
shoot
don't challenge me yeah that's what i
thought
coward where's banked have you seen bank
goddammit
i fenced off the whole place so we
wouldn't escape uh there's actually a
couple things i want to do today
the bees oh yeah i want to show the rtx
with uh that actually looks good because
apparently i had night vision on i don't
know what that means
and i want to fight the wither at the
end of this episode because
i thought putting a beacon on the
meatball might look really cool maybe i
should put on pb tower that'd be sick
i don't know meatball be sick too i
don't know this is the
this is the thing about minecraft
there's endless possibilities all right
let's check out rtx
and see what i did wrong i'll be i'll be
right back sven don't worry
look he's so sad every time i leave it
breaks my heart
wow me nvidia it took an hour to set
this up and it just looks like garbage
i don't know man it's kind of ugly i
don't get it like
where's the option for night vision i
don't have it look how good that looks
guys
oh god where's night vision hey look
there's a cat stinky cat and panda
they're not even supposed to be there
stinky stupid death cat he's just
pretending i know it
so yeah i think this will be the last
minecraft episode i do in a while
uh because i want to play the new
terraria update and i kind of
feel like i've done it all beast is kind
of like the last update i haven't really
checked out
and some people were complaining that it
was getting a bit dragged and i kind of
agree with you
if there's nothing to do in the game
it's kind of hard to just
i don't know this became so sad the
music and everything
hey does it still look bad i don't
yeah i mean
what do you think yeah text jurgen 3
what do you
think it is pleasant to look in the
distance i'll give him that
what do you think let me look at you
yeah yeah you oh god i killed
him i can't believe it yeah yeah it's
pretty
yo let me look at sven
there you are my man oh look at you they
look way better
i gotta say they look wet i don't i
don't know about jurgen though
he looked better before not gonna lie
maybe i'm using the wrong texture pack
let me change it okay so there's an
aquatic one
as well maybe the aquatic one looked
better yeah
okay wow all right that looked yeah it's
not all about you jurgen smergen
that looks [ __ ] good that looks
really good hold up
i like that a lot that looks beautiful
nvidia can i be in your video now whoa
looks so good
oh my god look at him i'm sticking
myself
look at the water man oh wow this is
cozy
whoa what the sheep
i love you he will not present himself
for me anymore
this is so sad okay this is very nice
look at the water i got the splash
i love how it reflects that's beautiful
kirena
all right so this is aquatic update this
should look good yeah i haven't ridden
you in a while
your friend escaped this is weird this
feels like
i'm doing something illegal you know oh
god for a water horse you sure stink
yeah this is way better look at that
can i see pp tower oh yeah oh yeah water
whoa that's beautiful
kind of kind of
look at the beginning of pp tower it's
foundation
glorious
god why is it so creepy in the water
stop it does my trampoline work
yeah it still works oh oh wait it does
work you just have to
yeah this is very comfy
very comfy i like this
this is a cool texture pack it'll
release it on not the windows 10
version nvidia god damn it's so lame
everyone's praising them i think it's
like come on release it for the java
version
i get that it's a beta but it's a beta
move too not gonna lie
i love it though that looks great
beautiful let's let's see it in the
night
oh the sun is going down dude look how
aesthetic that is
this brings me back memories man this
will be the last episode in a while
you look at it where you made and it's
kind of brings back the memory cena
building gear against memorial ikea
tower 2
ikea tower in the sky which i can't see
there it is
whoa
so beautiful the old church the
beautiful chickens
i guess it looks worse in nine because i
have night vision on i don't know
that looks sweet give me the feels isn't
that right sven
he looks like it's straight out of those
minecraft animations you ever heard of
those
that's beautiful i built that and this
is the snow left from the snowman like
20 episodes ago and then he died
we've done so much ikea tower
that started off as a little
all right we're not even done with the
episode come on all right i got to
switch it up sorry guys
b let's make sure oh god uh
it is nice though beastman follow me hey
follow me we got a ton of flowers let me
[ __ ] them
yeah you better come out and you better
follow me how the hell do i get them in
there i never even thought of that
hey hey hey don't run up don't run up
don't run
up i'm right here i'm not holding the r
i'm holding a rocket not a flower
stop him don't go in there sven you'll
drown
thank you all right follow me
thank you how do i get them out of there
oh look they're riding each other
that's so cute and also kind of hot not
gonna lie follow me oh god it's so loud
did i tell you to leave you're not
invited no one likes you
no no follow me you go in there we're
going in here okay
it's gonna be a wild ride but we gotta
do it man
follow god damn it
come in come in
yeah i don't even beat you up god damn
it
no sven don't come here
oh my god where did oh you're black now
all right that's cool it's so loud can
you turn it down in there
have you seen big where's the bee god
damn it get out
you can you can fly you can fly good job
sven
oh god i lose another bee i can't afford
losing bees
all right let's just take them now we're
gonna just move them
i i hate that thing so much there you
are oh perfect
yeah flying there dumbass oh my god he's
in
hell yeah this could not have worked out
any better all right
can i not fly through there okay okay
why do i still hear it god
okay cool now let's make it pretty with
all the flowers
let's make sure they can pollinate the
meatball it looks cool i like it
yeah i can't even see the bee it's i'm
sure it's
i'm sure it's enjoying life somewhere
all right let's put you there
wow what a pathetic tree jesus oh my god
they're so pathetic i guess there's not
enough
light okay look at that oh okay okay
okay
guys frick make baby
make baby oh my god it's tiny baby
now we kill it so they know they need to
work hard otherwise
that okay i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm
sorry i have been too violent lately
i want this to be a wholesome episode
all right so you guys better behave and
don't attack me because sven will kill
you
just make honey alright that's all i ask
i need honey for my fight against the
witcher i need to be stronger
sven let's go pluck some flowers like
the good old days
that's so cool i'm very happy with this
hey sven forgot the clothes day
all right watch this watch this 360.
clutch jump off be shut
yeah yeah look at that look i see the
bees
they love it in there look they're they
love it they love it so much in there
look at him
what oh no how damn it
oh my god i thought for how do i keep
killing everything
so when you didn't see anything don't
worry about it it must be la brita fita
it's the only explanation all right
let's get some flowers then let's go
this is a wholesome episode wholesome
god damn it
i'm plucking flowers with my bro i'm
gonna miss you while i'm done
i'll just be in another game all right
yes i'm using
a diamond because it's okay you'll
always be with me
what's that this is a good one yeah i
think so too
i think so too mate oh christman
you go make me cry it ain't over we're
to defeat the the weather smither
oh god there's another bee there i keep
escaping i hate them
should we kill it sven no this wholesome
episode
no more killing can i catch it while
flying that'd be sick
see if i can do that all right watch
this
where is it there you are no
come on come on i'ma catch you
oh i'm gonna ran into you yes ran
oh
[Laughter]
back to jail i mean your new home it's
different it's different trust me guys
it's way different i could just lure it
with flowers
but what's the point with that where's
the fun in that huh yeah my man sven
sven what up horsies gonna miss you too
not gonna lie i'm gonna miss you with
the most jurgen smirking
jurgens morning i flew again for
floating deep
gonna miss you too all right will it fly
in there automatically like last time
it seemed like they were kind of drawn
to there yeah yeah i get it
yeah i need to start breeding them more
now that i have flowers
yes you you breathe them with chicken
everyone knows this
this is gonna be pretty in here right
sven they're gonna like it here
you can come visit any time you want you
know just call me and i'll be there
you know i'll always be there for you
has the baby not grown up yet
can the babies freak oh i can make the
baby
oh my god is that is that what i think
it is
i got honey yes finally
you did something you stinky brain here
have some chicken
that's this is your reward
no flowers until chicken you gotta eat
your dinner first okay
they freak yes yes yes yes more yeah be
freaking
thank you minecraft you did look at that
look at that
egg sorry sorry oh no oh no oh god
do not attack them zen do not attack
them do not hurt the
children the women and the children sit
okay
it's cool it's cool we're cool i didn't
think an egg would do that
where's banked it's always going
somewhere this is where sven disappeared
the first time
i remember it's the water temple
the dolphins oh more flowers maybe i
should get some on the way
i'll probably come back to minecraft
whenever there's a new snapshot or
some update like that so don't worry
this is not the end
plus we have terraria to look forward to
nope damn it they think they can go
through the trap door
okay so i can't put a trapdoor there
yeah keep fricking
what do we want more freaking when do we
want it sven
yeah can they freak with these
yeah frick it will all frick i don't
care how close you are do bees care
about these things
i don't think so all right we got quite
a few going should i make the beast
fight the wither
it's tempting but i don't think it's a
good idea
all right sven what do you say mission
accomplished buddy
sven i know i know but we have to end
this
we don't want to be one of those washed
up minecraft channels trust me
follow me
i told you to leave god damn it why do
you guys be so cute and thick
all right it's the time sven i'll be
right back
i won't die don't worry i'm too strong
to die i just randomly got him
so i thought why have i not never uh oh
yeah i'm supposed to put the campfire
underneath i forgot about that oh and i
also
have another right we gotta juice up for
the deep don't cry
it's fine should i bring a kia bird with
me
low-key tempting all right apparently i
haven't done this on this one
we strong now brothers i gotta enchant
my diamond sword as well
my crappy elevator that doesn't work
spent so long building it oh god
sword sword sword my diamond sword sword
you cannot afford
hell yeah don't be scared sven let's
just wait for night to come
it's gonna be okay don't cry don't cry
where should we find it i do have this
underground
layer kind of down here that i never
used i used to just to find diamonds
and i know you're supposed to fight him
on the ground i didn't do it the first
one
oh my god it was so epic when we fought
the first one
maybe like in a cave like this would be
good i feel like i should back up my
save
nah that's for cowards backing up is for
children
i feel like this is genuinely a bad idea
but this is it
all right how was it i forgot is it like
this i don't remember
oh god i'm a little scared i've done it
before but it was tough
i have people that i love now so many
that i need to protect and not
kill because i don't kill anyone oh god
i should have built stairs god damn it
this is good because now i can make some
final adjustments before we go into
battle all right we're ready
for sweden
bon voyage my old friend
[Laughter]
oh i forgot the way their head god
dammit
okay all right i'm ready i'm ready you
got nothing on me
oh god i'm scared i'm scared i'm scared
i'm scared i regret everything
oh what is happening oh yeah you can't
attack it at me again i forgot all right
oh god oh god
man the weather is so tough oh god
i gotta do as much damage as i can
oh the weather is coming
no no you can't escape no window you
can't just escape
oh god what's he doing is he going to
second phase
he is got nothing
your mama's dead can i shoot him
look ah how do i kill him
this isn't fair titty shot
why isn't he dying do i have to hit him
oh i had to hit him oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh geez oh geez
jesus run into my face what is he doing
come back
hey he's a healing he's healing
oh god he's there now no you can't just
where the hell is he
[Music]
oh god this is so annoying haha you
can't go in here
dude i'm so much stronger now you're
weak
[Music]
oh god i gotta heal i gotta heal i gotta
heal don't shoot me okay
yeah hit him with the chicken oh god
he's broken through oh god
oh no
[Music]
oh god
did i do it i did it yeah
easy peasy on my teetsie yeah
yeah oh god i don't need these
i'm not poor all right cool we got
another netherstar sweet
let's build another beacon i did it guys
i did it
ikea bird i did it i'm a goddamn hero
i'm safe don't worry let's go on top of
ikea ball you'll always bring my
meatball though sven you know that
you'll always be my number one meatball
i forgot i forgot the goddamn materials
i'm such an idiot and i'll always be an
idiot god damn it and i don't have any
no can i jump up i'm sure i can jump up
i think i'm gonna have to get rid of the
elevator it's five by five isn't it
you ready for this then there it is what
do we want
jump boost there it is
we should put one on ikea tower in the
sky too isn't it beautiful sven
it's goddamn perfect look at that
oh that'd be sick to have a night well i
guess when i come back next time we'll
do it and i'll kill another wither
yeah it looks cool i kind of want it to
be yellow glass actually
how do i do it like that yeah we got the
blue oh my god that's so cool
yeah the prophecy
is complete sven sen come here i want to
say goodbye
i'll see you soon my man i'll see you
soon alright guys if you enjoyed this
episode uh
gently hit the tambourine button down
below we got merch
we got terraria coming up subscribe
and uh thanks for watching hit up
[Music]
[Applause]
do
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
bye